je vais prendre mon téléphone dans ces
cas là puisque je n'ai pas de réponse
par ailleurs alors nous commençons par
quel sujet mais ça ça va ça va rien dire
au public du tout ils ne sont pas prêts
sur l'a14 intéressant
ils sont prêts mais ils peuvent pas
commuté alors expliquez moi ce qui se
passe
à 6 le téléphone ne marche plus nous
sommes coupés du monde
bon très bien
bon il paraît que c'est une histoire de
commutation et entendu comme moi vous
dire exactement de quoi il s'agit où les
matchs pérou comme une sucette au départ
si c'était l'arrivée nous allons donc
commencer ce journal pardon alors j'ai
eu un espoir vu qu'on me rappelais pour
me dire que ça y était